so  [Music]  so  [Music]  can you handle more amazing news  i asked to be forgiven  [Music]  knowing the life that i've been living  we've both done terrible things in our  lives but everybody deserves a second  chance  i believe that you can be the version of  yourself that you want to be  i need a purpose forgiveness is  something that has to be earned it's  like that line in shoshenko redemption  get rich or die trying  if i don't do this i don't live  i have to do this to live  when i met mr cousino i was a lost soul  on my own he didn't just teach me how to  get better actor taught me how to be a  human being please help you save my life  you look good  so do you  [Music]  i'm like legit nervous we don't hear  from you two hours we'll all take  cyanide bills what job babies  you